the titan situation and look for those
of you out there who don't want to hear
about covet 19 even though it's an
important topic in the nfl it's 51
minutes after the hour we're only
addressing it now but two more titans
have tested positive we're still in the
potential not middle but close to the
end of the cascade of daily positives as
incubation periods expire and people
either do or don't test positive but we
know that the steelers and titans will
be playing week seven assuming there
isn't an extended outbreak or a fresh
outbreak
that's good news if they can pull it off
but uh you know shireen we still don't
know how deep this rabbit hole has gone
with the titans we still don't know that
the outbreak is over or ending anytime
soon and now we got to start thinking
about week five buffalo bills coming to
town will the titans be able to prepare
for that game
yeah will they be able to prepare first
of all and second of all how many of
those players who are now on the covet
list are going to be out for that game
probably all of them i would think and
now we have a big name on the list adam
humphries there are a lot of guys on
there you're like okay who's that guy
all right who's that guy but now you're
getting into name type players and there
may be more cases to come we don't know
so yeah it's going to be an interesting
week for the titans as we move forward
and and see what transpires over the
next few days they just seem to keep
coming but hopefully we're at the end of
this period where we don't see any more
positive cases
and let me just say this
now is the time for the nfl and the nfl
players association to be proactive for
whatever reason and i've been following
this sport every day for years and i've
been doing it professionally for
somewhere between 10 and 15 every single
day 20 since i started the website the
nfl notoriously fails to be proactive
this is the time for the league and the
union to get together and i firmly
believe shireen before we wait for the
next outbreak get every team into a
hotel hotel
practice hotel practice hotel airport
hotel in other city stadium airport
hotel very limited range of movement for
everyone connected the team that's the
only way to have confidence we're going
to get all these games in sharing
the only good thing is we have not seen
a positive test in baseball over the
last 30 days i think that's great news
that they might be able to do it this
way but they do need to be proactive
other than just sending a memo and say
hey you're wearing mask at practice hey
you're wearing gloves at practice
yeah and they need to clunk some heads
together because that thing we saw from
the raiders on monday night continues to
be stunning to me and i've been kind of
holding my breath all week for news that
some of those players are going to end
up testing positive and with the
incubation period right it could still
happen you know it could happen this
this weekend so uh
look we we all want the games to be
played but but i believe that and the
union needs to work with the league here
because the players lose their game
check shireen if games are missed that's
the one thing the union needs to
understand i hope the players understand
it too if games can't be made up those
those paychecks go away forever
we want to see football so do the right
thing and act out the way you're
supposed to be acting and stay out of
the public all those are really easy
things to do wear a mask
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports